let's go next to Jack from Connecticut
Jack welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
good afternoon David thank you for
having me my pleasure enjoy watching
your content and it is very informative
thank you
um despite the fact that Donald Trump
was in my opinion one of the worst
Presidents uh in American history he uh
was able to open the American people's
eyes on the importance but also
complicated process of American
democracy and I just want your opinion
what do you think will be the worst case
the best or worst case scenario uh in
the upcoming 2024 presidential election
well the the worst case is that Trump or
someone even worse becomes president and
and we again have a complete flouting of
norms and and and in many cases the law
the best case is that
you know a better candidate whether it's
Joe Biden or whoever wins and and
continues putting the country on a
slightly better path than it was headed
under Trump but I don't know that I
agree you know when when you said Jack
Trump opened the eyes of Americans to
the complexities of of our Democratic
process that's like putting a really
favorable spin on Trump basically
normalized authoritarianism among a
large swath of American voters I don't
know that it's really opening the eyes I
think it's I think that's too positive a
spin to put on what Trump did
of course absolutely I I absolutely hate
what he did on January it's like I was
just saying that from my perspective
because um I'm a big fan on US history I
was exempt from the U.S history Final in
high school there's a lot of things that
I did not know about in the process
because it wasn't really televised as
much the media wasn't paying oh Jack
you're you're saying you're saying quite
literally like you just learned about
the process for like certifying the
electoral votes like they're in the
nitty-gritty you're saying you didn't
know about that you learned about that
yeah oh okay okay and also the fact that
um people are paying much more attention
to that now as people as people have not
much has done in uh previous elections
okay that's that's fair that's fair I
think I thought you were saying
something different but uh yeah I mean
listen the worst case scenario for 24 is
very bad so let's work to prevent it
from becoming reality
100 yep all right my friend thank you
for the call thank you very much much
appreciated all right we are taking
calls right now if you'd like to speak
to me you can use the raise your hand
function which is a very very powerful
and important function I would say
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below